[Musique]
audace
critiquée
[Musique]
quatre ambulances et j'ai pas au centre
du h1n1 du strass ti j'ai commencé en
est ambulancier en 2006 j'ai vu titre ma
première fois aux tic et qu'on se
préparait pour tout cela que l'on au
virus qui s'en vient mon cachet trop de
capitaux est quand même y'a rien là je
me fais toujours que ce qu'on parte en
tournée pour le mois de mars nous on
avait 2 mars 2020 à 2 semblait bel 20 on
avait des spectacles toute l'année puis
à jamais marqués pour crever 19 tours
hangzhou serein sur un poste
la risée classant dans mon corps ce
pilote automatique
[Musique]
l'érotisme je suis un un acadien fier
acadienne de 40 ans qui est maintenant
proposé aux soins depuis le début du coc
vide ça me tentait pas de regarder le
plafond puis attendre que ça redevienne
normal y est comme un switch s'est
vraiment fait danser jours que tu
mangeras y travaillent j'ai fait de 16
en ambulance qu'est-ce que je peux faire
quand je pense je quitte ce monde ces
musiciens t comme premier regard des
tons sombres et tout le temps il ya
beaucoup de choses que c'est pas la tête
à ça n'engage en fermant des soins que
j'ai vu la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
samas l'estomac qui com - avant que je
travaille un foyer je pense que la
population est pas au courant à quel
point qu' on est à la veille d'un
tsunami gris au nouveau brunswick que
deux jeux 6 2 3 en soirée l'armée qui va
entrer ou la cour rouge pour entrer dans
les foyers
on y lol on est juste à la veille que
tout s'écroule je travaille il ya et à
des pianos un peu partout dans le foyer
pire il ya monsieur je jouais à l'oubli
ou pis de piste android et fo qui me
voit elle une pointe où il sourit tout
le temps
puis d'avoir des gens en a vraiment qui
réagit à la musique qui tape du pied ou
qui a souri des gens qui sont vraiment
plus haute
regarde le plafond longueur de journée
petit pingouin ou une mini réaction à ce
mouvement
je pense que je vais aller en nursing je
fais un nom je m'inscrive universités
pour faire mon bac
dans la section vip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
unis
avoir 40 ans dans la quarantaine ça fait
réfléchir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]